how's it going bros my name is Pam
welcome back I'm back we're all back I
miss you
anyway welcome to Gary's demo as per my
advice about Steph Liske which is south
Swedish and he doesn't like to write his
name properly either side mm-hmm to
think that they're having a party with
my good friends could end in such a this
answer all right this sounds like an
excellent modern way okay yeah you can
tell just by like this story of the
thing that it's just gonna be something
really shitty I want to start white
knight I know I said I wasn't gonna do
it but right now I just want to play
something really weird so oh man I
really I drank a lot like that now I
remember injury when I want to wear oh
man I'm so drunk
look I'm super short I've heard down I'm
idiots that's good
oh man I'm too short the life of a
[ __ ] oh oh wait do we already have its
cited for sure I thought for a second it
was live man
am i crawling on my [ __ ] I can't think
of what's funnier
I think midges good I made you I'm a
minute I'm a minute Oh like a nutshell
ha PT Ayala
okay
I don't like bunny Wow it's up drunk
come on I'm still drunk no it's bad
enough sand erosion helps for being
drunk apparently I should
oh [ __ ] that's Tom yeah the hell
happened to Tom I come on Tom get out oh
wow that's creepy okay
living room so they're having sex in the
other room I would have seen
all right ladies a girl with her maybe
Tom did something bad over here - that
is it's locked
I just frickin open it Wow okay what
happened here mr. chair I don't know man
hours a lot of noise and check girl
juices flowing everyone man don't tell
me more
it's disgusting
double wedding and I'm Adam Adam um oh
my oh yes I can't see [ __ ]
that was that with that that wasn't
Tom's girl she was not good-looking
that's oh look
Cammy like I don't have anything about
this it's going all in there
why does everything have to be locked I
have to agree everything has to be like
I guess that's Allen
sorry about that Allen he was she did
really
he was damn sexy though oh man look at
that arm
are you touching yourself Allen why are
you touching yourself that's disgusting
all right I can't we need to find a key
and it's got to be here somewhere
it's just so frickin I need to find the
lantern away come on
I need Stefano or someone I mean we were
partying last night so he's gotta be
here somewhere okay we have some more of
the juice yes not drunk anymore I mean
what that's bad seriously though it's so
freaking dark okay maybe in here
no probably probably not just for my
alright could be in here tell me was
James I don't know our shape okay
really though wait maybe this is lock
now alright look everywhere come on oh
hi I need me [ __ ] for that but I don't
Alan is there a clue Alan where's the
key oh come on he doesn't ask me what an
[ __ ]
this room getting smaller
it's my penis getting bigger what really
though this is so buggy I get the
feeling like I missed the keys in some
while the room or some [ __ ]
ah man
like this chick momentos search after
the key oh wow this clue ever that's
what I'm doing doing come on come and
cry I can totally fit there like if I
could squeeze my butt cheeks I don't
even know what that is but it's
something ok it's not here no no
why does both come on oh uh Jenna - wait
did I pick up something else no I just
in too much okay it's good though we
need ten of my stink bugs aren't good
come on
demo I wonder what the full release is
gonna be like so stupid oh here it is
finally just pick come pong uh block it
mr. chair okay fine oh but okay you look
at that book no let's see me oh go on
oh man he's always so sexy oh come on
don't look at him
are we good we're good we are really
good
I'm so good you're good we're not good
mr. champ there's something do something
they don't even know oh okay wait wait
okay we're good we're good
it's chip mr. [ __ ] oh oh come on you
can't push the hits please
I didn't bear today oh
okay let's do that I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got it I got it I got
it okay okay okay oh [ __ ] something
happened
I told you to run you told me to hide it
if I can tell me to run okay I think
it's good enough it's fine
sings what happened last night I was so
drunk and um man mr. Sher you did
nothing I'm sorry Petey
I'm really shy I did all I cried for
your kids okay I trust II shares
Arbroath seriously though I guess oh
it's open
really oh great oh [ __ ] the line you
broke I didn't even have a lantern if
you read this then I guess you didn't
they didn't get you actually they did
get me some thanks anyway I've taken a
refugee a bit from your location just
continue down this all the way and your
shoe find me hopefully I'll still be
alive
hopefully I don't even know who you are
I don't want you to be alive is it my
girl oh come here
no no focus okay
perfect excellent the fog is gone yeah
is that a butter knife nice this night
oh [ __ ] that's awesome I'm taking this
with me someone upstairs
no come on door oh yeah
don't you die River what's gonna Ohno
don't tell me that
what
the [ __ ] is going on
ah okay that's bad that's illegal let's
just go
this is Oh
locked you must be joking
take it baby baby baby oh man thank you
for playing okay I think that was
probably [ __ ] is one so far but whatever
I just got back and we moved in
apartment I just wanted something really
quick for you guys so I hope you enjoyed
it and I'll see you tomorrow with a
proper proper one
I don't want to be patient I wanna be
major are you [ __ ] kidding me
be patient suck my back